in this video we're going to be talking
about f strings and some of the cool
things that you can do with them
so most of you are probably already
aware of what f strings are
it's this kind of notation where you can
put in
f little f or capital f it actually
doesn't matter
and then you have some literal stuff and
then within the string you can put more
python code
so this is really useful and it was
introduced in i think python let's see
python 3.6
but what you may not know is that
there's a lot of extra stuff that you
can put in between these curly braces to
modify what actually gets printed here
so in this first example we're just
printing something out and you would
just see
the value is
other dog face
but one of the really cool things that
you can do is just put an equal sign
afterwards and then that will actually
print out
basically
what's
before the equal sign
then the equal sign and then the value
of what's before the equal sign so if we
go ahead and run this code
let me go ahead and make this bigger for
you
you can see the first one we just have
the value is other dog face and then in
the second one we see string value
equals and then the wrapper of that
variable so this is extremely useful
especially for debugging purposes if
there's
some variable in your code like num
value and i just want to add a quick
debug print statement i can just say oh
let me add in
num value equals kind of print statement
in here and then immediately you can see
it comes out as num value equals
something
and that's really useful i wouldn't
really use it in production code but
especially for debugging purposes it
you know i end up using it a lot more
than i probably should
another cool thing about this is that
you can actually add spaces basically
anywhere in there and it will preserve
the spaces so
if you really like having you know
everything nicely printed out then you
can do that put a space before and after
in here and you see it down here when
it's printed out
and this last example you can see that
you can actually have arbitrary
expressions there and so it will print
out you see num value percent two num
value percent two that part just gets
printed out and then the value of that
expression gets substituted after the
equal sign
so that's a really cool hidden trick of
f strings that you might not have known
about even though f strings have been in
python
since python 3.6 this equal sign ability
has only been in since python 3.8 so if
you're not using a pretty recent version
of python then you might not have access
to this yet but if you do that's great
it's super useful
okay next example conversions so if
you're not aware inside the curly braces
of an f string after the expression you
can put a
exclamation point a
exclamation point r or exclamation point
s and what these do is instead of
printing the value of this thing it will
additionally do some
extra thing on top of that so r
we'll call the wrapper so
this one right here let's print it out
you can see that
i get the quotes in the string printed
out with it and that's because the
wrapper of a string actually has the
quotes in it so
this second one here is actually
equivalent to if i said
print the wrapper out
the reason that you would want to use
this
bang r instead of writing wrapper out is
because
you're probably doing this for debugging
purposes
let's say that thing that you actually
wanted to print out was you know a nice
formatted thing string value
but something wasn't working quite right
so
you say let me just print out the
wrapper so i can see exactly what's
being printed and that will help clear
things up
so
what's this bang a here this exclamation
point a that actually stands for ascii
so if you are not familiar with what
that does
it's
similar to wrapper it's very similar to
wrapper except that all of the
basically non-ascii characters get
replaced by
an ascii safe escaped version of it so
this dog face that i have here
you know really cute but um
if we're limited to just ascii strings i
need to escape that with this backslash
u 0 0 1 f kind of stuff
so
in python 3 i don't really see a big
need for
doing this kind of thing
but this is more similar to how
python 2 wrappers worked
but maybe you just don't want to print
out dog faces because
you know
well i don't know why anyone wouldn't
want to print out a dog face instead of
this nasty thing but
i guess you can do that and then of
course your next question is probably
well you said there was a r and s so
what's the purpose of s
well if you do that it calls
the string conversion operator on the
type and you might think well why would
i ever want to do that when
the
default is to do that you know if i did
nothing
what it's going to do is call the string
conversion operator and print it out
that way it's not going to print out the
wrapper
and the reason that this bang s exists
is because
this actually gets applied before
another thing that you can do which is
formatting and that'll be our next
example so if you're wondering about the
bang s it's for
formatting
so if you do one of these things and
then do something that i'm going to show
you in the formatting operator it will
apply this either string conversion or
wrapper conversion or ascii conversion
and then apply the formatting after that
so
it can be useful i usually don't ever do
that though
okay so let's get to the formatting
example here
so i've got a whole bunch of little
examples and we'll just you know see how
they all work so basically every type
can define what it means to define its
own formatting so i have here you know a
float value and here i have a date time
and in my f string i can put a colon and
then format string so the format strings
are actually specific to the type so
the things that i can put here for a
date time are different than the things
that i put here for a numeric value so
you can see here if i have a date time i
can print it out year month day like
that and that'll work so i'll go ahead
and run it and you can see
now equals 2021 06 14. so that format
string works for date times and then for
you know numeric values this point to f
is actually a
format string telling me i want two
decimal places so you don't have to
manually round things you can just say i
want two decimal places and then the
formatting library
or the formatting function within
the number class that you're using will
handle the rounding and displaying part
for you
so what's actually going on under the
hood here is a little bit easier to see
if you define your own class so here
i've defined this my class
and let's see what it does
it's just an empty class and all it does
is define a format method which takes a
format spec and is supposed to return a
string
so let's see what happens
when we use our own class
in one of these format you know things
and see what actually happens when it
gets called so when i go ahead and run
it you can see
that i see my class
dunder format called with format spec
equals blah blah blah so you can see
this blah blah my format stuff is
exactly what was after the colon inside
of the f string in the curly braces
so that is getting passed as an argument
the format's back argument to the dunder
format
method of the class
and
you can do whatever you want with that
information so it's totally up to you
in this case i just
you know totally ignored the information
and just always return my class open
close paren
this is a way to allow your own class to
decide
what are some special ways that i can be
printed out
so
that's
not something that i do super often
but
it's kind of more important that you
just know that that's what the syntax is
doing basically whatever you pass here
is just getting passed to a special
function of the class
and so you can look up each class in the
documentation is going to tell you
what its format strings are and you know
how to make use of them so especially
for numbers this you know automatically
rounding to two decimal places i do that
all the time so just be aware that
that's another thing
all right well that's all i've got on f
strings and little f string tricks i
hope you enjoyed this little
more informal video
and i just wanted to give a quick shout
out to my patrons on patreon thank you
guys so much i really appreciate your
support
see you next time